I am so happy and excited for my
daughter oh I don't have a daughter
but
um when I'm when I'm texting Chloe I
always put to my daughter ladies and
gentlemen we think so much for this day
it's a blessing for Chloe and Tristan
amen amen Khloe Kardashian honors
Tristan Thompson's mom Andrea two weeks
after her sudden death earlier this
month the NBA star's mom died at her
home in Toronto Andrea reportedly
suffered a fatal heart attack and on
Tuesday Chloe penned a touching tribute
to her ex's mom on Instagram writing
that she feels numb and while this has
been one of the toughest times of her
life at the same time she feels blessed
to have had someone that makes saying
goodbye so incredibly difficult quote
I'm choosing to say that until I see you
again in heaven I miss you and I will
continue to miss you more and more every
single day the reality star added that
she knows Andrea who is Mom to Tristan
and his three younger brothers DeSean
Daniel and Amari never wanted to leave
her boys quote they are your entire
world they will learn to live with a
hole in their hearts because they are
warriors just like their Warrior mommy
Coco concluded her post making a promise
to look after help and protect Amari who
has epilepsy before adding one final
message to Andrea I love you I love you
I love you
Chloe and Tristan share two children
together four-year-old daughter true and
a five-month-old son whose name they
have not yet shared publicly the two
split in December 2021 while expecting
baby number two because Tristan had
cheated on Chloe fathering another child
with a different woman but on Tuesday
Chloe shared this sweet clip from a
happier time her 2018 baby shower with
Andrea in attendance we are Beyond
excited and thrilled to welcome another
my ninth grandchild
that's a lot of people that's a lot of
human beings it's Andrea's first
granddaughter
Tristan's mom
is here with us today Andrea
[Music]
excited for my daughter
Chloe her sister Kim and their mom Kris
Jenner all attended Andrea's funeral in
Toronto at the time Chris shared several
snaps to Instagram writing that she was
heartbroken by the news adding quote you
were the most amazing dedicated devoted
and selfless mom and such a loving kind
and fabulous grandmother
foreign
[Music]